You know what? Your kids want
so much more than three hours of you standing in the kitchen
making pasta by hand, making meatballs by hand,
and marinara sauce from scratch from tomatoes.
Do you know what they would rather have?
They would rather have played a game with you.
They would have rather played hide and seek.
And that's the goal of this tried wife bullshit.
You're gonna have all these kids because I know you want them.
Because that's your little heart's desire.
Cause we as a fucking nation,
as a culture, as a world,
have groomed you as a woman to think your only fucking worth is life
is when you have children.
So because you have this burning
fire desire in your heart to be a mother,
I'm gonna give you an insurmountable amount of children.
It's like the parent of the 50s who makes you sit in that.
They catch you smoking cigarettes
and then they make you smoke a whole entire pack.
It's like, oh, yeah,
you wanna be a mom? You wanna be a mom?
I'm gonna give you so many kids
that it's hard to be there for everything that they need.
It's gonna be hard to enjoy their moments
because you're always riddled with guilt
of what you're not doing for one of the other kids.
And then I'm gonna put this requirement of everything home cooked
so that you don't even get to mother them the way you want.
You Don't get to spend time with them the way that you want.
And you don't have memories with them like you want.
That the kids are off doing whatever fuck all shit that they're doing
while you're in the kitchen cooking.
And the kids would much rather have memories of.
Mom pushed me on the swings.
Mom sat down and watched a movie with me.
Mommy, you know,
snuggled with me, and we had a tea party with my bears.
So you don't have to wonder
what the fuck happens at the end of Ballerina Farm.
You can see what happens
from just looking all the fucking way around you.